the place I go to which is [ __ ]
tremendous and if you need a massage
you go in there some nights I going on
date night with my wife they [ __ ] put
your feet in the buckets they rub you
down and do your shoulders your neck
sometimes I had only one people rub my
feet I got that [ __ ] fungi toenail
[ __ ] Chinese hand on my fungi don't
know they just let it out the [ __ ]
people oh no this is [ __ ] let me just
go as if you were patient zero what's
that if they're rubbing your feet and
then it spreads all these people and
they have gone trace it back yeah yeah
I'm the [ __ ] I got a fun night
so now I even got the groom on to get a
blow torched really because you go up in
the valley and the lady comes in it
would blow it cold they're like crowd
therapy that bad mm-hmm and the other
chick comes with a blowtorch and they
try to blow the fungus away you gotta
smell that you gotta smell that oh I did
like six appointments where they tried
to burn the fungus off oh my god this
won't work the toenail was on fire no it
spread to the other one so now I got the
big one and the one next to it lon and
here's the ugliest thing in the world
looks like one [ __ ] host from an
eagle every jitsu I try to hide it with
a band-aid but it cuts right through the
band-aid it's horrible I don't know what
I was to do is there anything you could
apply topically or does it have to be a
pill I've done everything I've done
everything what the best thing I do is I
cut it and when I take the grinder and I
grinded into like coke powder you have
to smell that powder to believe it well
it is so stinky but I will grind those
first two toes it's like a [ __ ] thing
like like you're standing your toes oh
yeah it's a sand that I got the extra
rock for like I had my wife go on Amazon
and get like the [ __ ] [ __ ] Obama
stone Autobody [ __ ] and I just [ __ ]
sad that [ __ ] toenail down if I saw
him to tell them oh I don't even know
Jesus Christ